hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kleinen info video was ich mal so
ganz am rande macher und zwar wollte ich
ein etwas anderes thema heute ansprechen
und zwar ist ja gerade sonntagabend um
20 26 hier unten und schwer erkennen
könnt und ich habe gestern morgen bis
gestern um 1 uhr mit vier freunden ein
video aufgenommen ein musikvideo zwei
haben gesungen und 2 haben wir beide
technik kamera etc geholfen und dieses
wieder habe ich nun fertig geschnitten
so soll das alles dann nachher aus also
ich habe dann alles zusammen geschnitten
ein paar übergängen überhänge nicht
übergängen und so weiter also dass das
wirklich ein bisschen dass man ein paar
verschiedene sichten hat hier zum
beispiel wo man die vier sicht und so
weiter aber das soll ich auch gar nicht
interessieren behalte sie ins kommt
vielleicht noch mal irgendwann und
jedenfalls haben wir das video jetzt
hochgeladen das findet ihr bei jonathan
theresa music so heißt der kanal in der
beschreibung bzw
also der kanals in der beschreibung und
so heißt auch der kanal dort findet ihr
das video das videos ganz oben in der
beschreibung
und das wäre ich zu verwenden da einfach
drauf geht das irgendwie leicht
verbreitet oder irgendwie sowas weil es
recht eine menge arbeit das alles zu
drehen wir hatten nicht so super
equipment mit so richtig richtig tollen
lichtern und so werden so eine garten
lampe improvisations mäßig sage ich
einfach genommen und das war schon recht
gut sagt mir dass es überhaupt
hingekriegt haben deswegen wäre es echt
super wenn ihr euch einfach das video
ansehen würde und keine ahnung ist licon
wird oder es wenigstens verbreiten würde
irgendwie sowas also damit würdet ihr
mir beziehungsweise und schon großen
gefallen tun
und ja das wollte ich einfach nur ganz
kurz sagen und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns morgen wieder in der today
show wenn die morgen wieder kommt
nackten schönen abend und ja